of course this is based on a true story
but it's also a mystery and it's a
thriller and i wondered what were both
of your reactions when you first read
the ending when you first saw how it
would all come out in the end
oh wow
i mean
it's devastating um
justice is done which is nice
but my gosh the road to getting there is
painful um but it's gratifying
heavenly father
we ask that we might be instruments in
my hand
to fix what we find broken
in the name of jesus christ
amen i don't know for my character
anyway it leaves a lot of questions
unanswered and a kind of
a new beginning into a new a new way of
living uh that's that's interesting too
but hopefully i think i i like what
lance has done with the series
especially in the end is that it's it's
given power much more power to the women
in the show specifically brenda lafferty
and diane lafferty that denise goff
plays and chloe perry's character as
well so let's hope that there's
definitely some hope there yeah
gil it leaves a sting you know it's kind
of weird because there's a resolution
but it was a painful route to get to and
it was just it was horrifying
to um understand that human beings
for
the reasons that they had justified to
themselves
uh could commit this murder
um but then it's it's a deeper
a deeper dive into the the
belief system and where it originated
from and how it evolved to get to where
it is now
um
so there's some satisfaction like andrew
said
but i think it feels like it leaves a
scar you know in your soul would you two
reprise these roles in a different
mystery i think no you're like too much
okay
you mean the sequel
[Laughter]
over the banner of heaven
heads up right now
goes beyond just a murder
beyond everything i believe
andrew my my producer is convinced like
you play this guy he's such a good guy
and we see him being a father and
incredible husband and
she thinks that fans are gonna have a
real crush on this detective so are you
ready for that
like like a dilf
like a dill yeah detective they'd like
to and dad it works a detective they'd
like to
[Laughter]
yeah i mean
listen i'm just trying to i'm just
trying to give give the people what they
want yeah so that's i'm in the business
there you have it i'm just in the
business of pleasing that's all i'm here
to serve protect and surf you know he
again he's such a good guy and then
you're
these two are up against
this darkness as you said um would did
you two get it all tempted to take on
the villain the more villainous roles
here or could we see either of you play
a villain in the future because i know
you both now from these shows where you
you're driven by very good better
pursuits i know i guess it's the nature
of who we are huh
i mean you're a spider-man you were we
can't change our essence yeah and it's
just good yes it's just pure we are just
angels on earth and i i don't know if uh
you know we could try but i think we'd
end up just you know spreading love in
our villainy somehow yeah
we'll create a new villainy yeah
the good kind okay great
another fun answer thank you
gil i know you're starting yellowstone
again soon are you a fan of oh come on
everybody come on up everybody loves
yellows yeah we're obsessed do you are
you obsessed andrew i've never seen
yellows
i just know everyone loves yellows
everyone loves it i was with this guy
day in day out for six months i'm not
going to go home and watch more of this
guys
like get away from me well you need to
watch it
you need to watch it
no i hear it's incredible everyone i
know is insane about it my publicist
brianna my personal trainer eric my my
my pancake mixer
like i'm just listing all them
i don't have stuff no but all of my
friends love it so much and i and i i am
going to engage i promise you i will
engage okay well andrea was wondering
you've been very busy are you going to
take a vacation and watch yellowstone
i'm going to take it
i'm going to go and visit gill on this
on the set yeah i'm going to get him on
he's a last order now yeah yeah last two
i mean the background is last suing and
every shot the guild's in just like some
white guy behind him trying to lasso i
um i know i uh i'm definitely going to
take some time i'm definitely going to
watch yellowstone especially after this
and don't know pressure yeah gill's
gonna keep it keep the party going may i
ask you a serious question i have to
tell you watching the scenes
with the detective and his mother were
so beautiful and so touching and
obviously and i'm i'm so sorry that
you've been through the loss of your own
mother i wondered what those scenes were
like for you and how much you brought
yourself into it or put a wall up if you
needed to because they're really really
beautiful well that's kind of you and i
know i mean it's you know i you bring
everything of yourself that's for me
that's the job and and you kind of um
kind of have to make it as personal as
possible and and that's the beauty of it
you know we get to we get to express
you know our own personal experiences
and emotions and make and turn them into
art and hopefully people will
feel more permission to feel what they
feel in their lives by seeing someone
else going through something as a
character and
and it was a particularly special
because the woman who's playing my
mother in the show is a woman called
sandra c cat who is maybe the greatest
acting teacher alive um she is a legend
in the field of of acting teaching and
she's been my teacher with
her and her daughter have been my
teachers for the last 15 years and that
they are my kind of extended family and
when i read the script i was working
with
my acting teacher greta who's sandra's
daughter i said you know greta was like
well sandra should play this part and
and i said that's the most beautiful
idea i've ever heard and so i i brought
it to the director david and lance and i
said what do you guys think and they met
sandra and they immediately felt
everyone falls in love with sandra she
is
this kind of open vessel of humanity and
is just the most beautiful spirit and
has become a surrogate mother to me over
the course of the last years and so to
be able to play out those scenes with
her was particular and intimate so
intimate that relationship and again
just like gil and i we immediately
became very very close
and kind of had us had a kind of a real
connection and a love for each other i
think and that reads on camera and the
same thing with with sandra and myself
that we didn't have to act it was just
they the camera was rolling we were just
being together and loving each other and
it was a beautiful thing
[Music]
you